[Music]
democrats and the media being accused of
anti-cop rhetoric it's over their
reaction to a police officer
fatally shooting an ohio teenager who
was holding a knife
micaiah bryant in new york city
demonstrators clashing with law
enforcement
and spray painting slogans like f the
police on statues
democrats and the press being criticized
for saying bryant was involved in a
typical
teenager fight and the officer should
have acted differently
the columbus police union president he's
pushing back against that
saying bashing the cops make the people
that they protect
less safe take a look it doesn't fit an
agenda that's being pushed around this
entire country certainly
in ohio here in columbus the same day we
had this tragic shooting
that the officer was involved in we had
a 15 year old
shoot another 15 year old in cincinnati
not far from us earlier in the week a 13
year old stabbed
another 13 year old it's everywhere
we're not even hearing about those the
police have been demonizing this entire
country
and when we're trying to catch up now
it's made criminals feel
emboldened to be do these crimes of
violence
jesse uh so what we have here is a
situation where
you have the police officers union
standing up for them and i think
that's right but there's a new poll out
today from the washington post it says
60 percent of americans say the united
states
needs to do more to hold police
accountable for mistreating black people
and that includes 30 percent of
republicans what do you think jesse
i think if you mistreat anyone black or
white you need to be held accountable
and that's what we saw in the derek
chovin trial
but i just want to take this instance
and extrapolate it
black americans are calling 9-1-1 for
help juan
because someone has committed a crime in
their neighborhood and police are
arriving
to help black americans and 99.999
percent of the time that situation's
handled
perfectly and then in that very very
very small percentage
there's a tragedy someone loses a life
and it's very complex but what the media
does is they jump in
and they create a narrative that white
police officers are hunting down and
murdering black people who are innocent
that is not the case and that is not
supported by the facts
and they do this for two reasons they do
this for one reason to take the
attention away from black on black crime
and put attention on the police they
also do this to increase
black americans fear of white police
officers so they continue to vote
for democrats and when a republican
comes up and tries to speak about the
facts of a case
the media says that republican is racist
they do that to scare them strike fear
in their hearts
so they shut up and don't speak their
minds this is how
the media controls us through fear and
divides us
for power in reality juan and i know you
know this
blacks and whites in america get along
great
you go to a washington football game you
go to a nationals game
you go to the train the gas station the
bar the restaurant
everyone does their thing everyone's
doing just fine
and you also know black americans don't
have a huge
problem with police for the most part
black americans don't want to defund the
police
they want more police they want fast
response times
they just want robust police who are
respectful
everybody agrees on that so
what's holding us back the media is
holding us back
we have a lot of love for one another in
this country and we've come a long way
on race
but we're not there yet and there's one
obstacle in the way one and it's the
media who continues to divide us for
power
all right uh that's one perspective so
greg in the congress you have
tim scott the republican senator from
south carolina cory booker
republican from new jersey karen bass in
the house the
congresswoman from california they say
they're on the verge of some kind of
compromise on police reform likely to
include
lessening what's called qualified
immunity
for prosecution uh for police so that
they could be held more accountable
what do you think of this compromise are
you optimistic um
i hope so i'm for any kind of compromise
as you know
but to pick up on what jesse's saying if
this
issue this police issue was reported
with accurate data on race and police
shootings we would actually get a proper
perspective
that would allow us as a country to
focus on the social problems
that lead to those tragic spectacles in
the final moments
that we see in the video we are only
reacting
to the final video and yet somehow
we ignore all the moments that led to
that point
activists have called us racist when we
talk about crimes black on black crime
like that stabbing because in fact
those activists are racist they
completely abandoned the standards for
blacks they just say
when you talk about black on black crime
as we have on the five
about when we were talking about the
chicago explosion in crime
what was the what was the the response
hey that's just
gangs that's just gang's crime that
doesn't affect you
don't worry about it in this case hey
it's just knives
just people having an average teenage
knife fight
that lowering of standards of accepting
that behavior
that's as racist as hell it's offensive
and it leads to these that's what leads
to these 9-1-1
calls that what triggered that call was
the ending of a sad
life what mainstream media loves to
ignore
why was she in foster care what was the
fight about why was that guy kicking a
woman
none of these questions matter just like
what happened in chicago
all that stuff that you ignore allows
this narrative to continue
and these uh emotional horrifying videos
to continue
so instead the media as you bring up the
reform
the media wants us to focus on the one
person
the one person who must intervene
because that's his job
the cop they target the guy who has to
address the problem
that the activists and the media have
ignored for decades
it's on that one guy in that one moment
and nobody has mercy on him
okay so deagon uh you know
i think that you know a lot of the
liberal left
went too far and start talking about
things like defund the police but
looking at this poll that i was
mentioning to
jesse and greg you got like 63 percent
of american adults people of all colors
saying there's not equal treatment in
the criminal justice system
for black americans that includes a
third by the way of republicans who
agree with that
but you know you hear people say well
it's the media or whatever
but it's like 80 to 90 percent of black
people say they're not treated equally
in the criminal
justice system what do you make of this
tim scott has talked about that how many
times has he been pulled over
for just for no reason
quite frankly but to greg's point the
one thing that we never talk about
is the media will always go
to racism anti-asian crime
anti-black crime but they never talk
about mental illness
and one quarter of all fatal police
shootings
involve a person with a mental illness
but we don't talk about that and we do
nothing quite frankly to address it
or address the preparedness of officers
for that i think that most states
require less than eight hours of
training in dealing with a mentally ill
person
but one to your point like we're really
these left-wing mouthpieces are really
plumbing new depths of dumbassery
talking about not knives aren't
dangerous
or police need to stop doing all traffic
stops
the attorney general in new york has
talked about stopping routine traffic
stops
oh so when you get beat up by a lunatic
what's the message then suck it up and
put some makeup on your bruises or your
house gets robbed
who needs three tv sets that's just
materialistic
this demonization of police officers is
going to have the effect of defunding
the police
police officers are retiring they're
afraid to do their jobs
and young smart talented people will
never
join a police force they will never make
their career and dedicate their life to
public safety and i know that for a fact
because i talked to a police officer
today
30 years on the force three decades
protecting the lives of new yorkers two
sons
college age and he said i cannot and
will not tell them to go to the academy
and join the forest they won't be
allowed to do their job and their lives
would be in danger
to back that up i talked to the
fraternal order of police joe gomaldi
today 16 years in the police force
talking about morale at an all-time low
it was
a stark warning about what is happening
with our
the members of our police force across
the country right now i hope i speak for
so many americans who live in towns
across
america who enjoy the safety of their
police departments knowing to jesse's
point that 99
of the time those police officers are
responding on the other end of 9-1-1 and
they are coming in to help
you your family your neighbors we need
to say
thank you more and i will end with this
joy behar today
questioning police tactics tactics that
are banned
in police departments across the country
like why didn't you fire a warning shot
that's not allowed and that is not a
part of police training
taxes joe gamaldi said what goes up must
come down
they are not allowed to do that so to
his point his concern
is that in the media there is a
narrative out there being
pushed and questions being asked that
are clearly
not researched and not based on fact and
that's a
very dangerous thing for for viewers on
a lot of these networks that are hearing
that
to hear and i think you're right sandra
i think
yesterday i was one of the people who
said you know what can you do
to try to distract this woman could you
fire a gun in the air
because you know the police work is
tough but of course taking a human life
you know that's final and so the
question was is there a way
to deal with it now police have to go
through extreme training
and we have to respect that i